Why is it important to take your family on vacation?
They work a lot.
When your dad or mom goes to work, you don't get to see them that much.
My parents always go on business trips, so they deserve a little break.
Where would you like to take your parents?
Albany.
Albany?
Because it's the capital of famous New York.
To the Dominican Republic.
I mean the North Carolina.
I forgot.
I kinda forgot, let me just...
No, you take your time!
Anywhere with too many fur animals there,...
...I cannot go because my dad is allergic to any kind of fur.
Any other must-haves for this vacation?
You need to have a bathroom.
Okay, I'm writing these down.
Yeah, of course a diving board!
Okay, okay.
Then I can dive.
How much do you think that this whole flight and hotel would cost?
Four bucks.
You're right.
One, two, that should do it.
Three flights and hotel for Tampa Bay, Florida.
I want to see the world with my parents.